Hey, everybody, Welcome to Citizen by CNN I'm
dana bash and I'm here with three of my esteemed
colleagues to talk about. You guessed it, the
midterm elections. It's hard to believe that we're
talking less than two months before Election Day,
where all of the House of Representatives, a third
of the United States, Senate governors, races and
legislatures all across the country are all up for
grabs. So we want to hear from you as we discuss
these topics. If you want to submit a question,
please submit in the box next to the right of the
player. Um if you don't know these very familiar
faces, I'll just formally introduced Youtube
Manu Raju, our chief congressional correspondent,
john King who is the anchor of Inside Politics
and also chief national correspondent and Daniel
Daniella Diaz, who is our congressional
reporter. Hi guys, thank you so much. Um, so
so much to discuss. I want to
start with you manu because
um you walk the halls, well, they were
gone for a month or so, uh they meeting
members of Congress who were on the ballot, but
you're walking the halls, they're back now. What
are you hearing there from them? And I know you're
out in the field as well. But just start with what
you're hearing that now that they're back. What's
the mood among both republicans and democrats
as we head into the election? Well, it's tense. I
mean, any time you get this close to the midterms,
both sides recognize that any single event could
upend things could change the dynamics of a race
could determine how the control of Congress
could come down. And of course, as we know,
the Senate is still on a knife's edge. I mean,
the republicans recognize that there is an uphill
climb to take back the Senate, no doubt about it.
They have struggled in fundraising in some cases,
some of candidates have underperformed on the
campaign trail that a lot of rookie candidates
and some key races and the democrats appear feel
like they have a bit of an edge heading into
the final stretch, but they are by no means over
confident about what will happen here. But on the
seventh side of the House is not back yet and the
House republicans, they are still confident they
will take back the majority of the House and the
margins of may not be as big as they once wanted,
but once had hoped, but undoubtedly they are still
favored. But senate republicans are concerned
about their cash shortfall right now. The National
Republican Senatorial Committee, the committee,
of course, is central to propping up incumbent
senators. They're spending money against democrats
and playing a big role down the stretch. They
have burned through enormous amounts of cash, 95%
or so of their cash and tv ad they've already
run and a digital fundraising operation that
did not that sort of went awry as a result,
there is concern that the committee may not
play its traditional role in helping turn out
voters through direct mail. In the final weeks
of the campaign. We're trying to figure
out other ways to make up for that funding
shortfall. And right now behind closed doors.
Republican senators are meeting after news about
problems with the fundraisers have come to light
and after rick scott, the committee chairman
went after mitch McConnell in an op ed suggesting
McConnell's concerns about candidate quality
hurt Republican candidates and almost treasonous.
Now scott did not call out McConnell by name
and denied that he was referring to McConnell,
but it was widely interpreted as a shot of the GOP
leader. So all those tensions are still playing
out behind the scenes, behind closed doors,
as republicans recognize they have a hill
to climb. They can get back to the majority,
but it's not gonna be easy in the final two months
here, john, you've covered a few midterm elections
in your time. And you know, the history, if
you look at history except for after 9 11,
the midterms. After 9 11, when
republicans held the held Congress,
even though there was a Republican in
the White House. History shows us that
the opposing party should do well even take over
at least one branch of the House, not one branch,
one house, either the Senate or the House,
because there's a democrat in the White House.
Do you think that you see any signs that this
could be a year where history could be bucked
based on anything that you're seeing you do in
recent days for a number of reasons recent days.
Last few weeks. You can actually go back to the
Dobbs decision when Dobbs replaced roe v wade,
the abortion rights decision of the Supreme
Court reset the map and reset the dynamic now.
You know, it's cliche but true that 8.5 weeks
is a long time. So let's wait and see what
happens. Eight weeks is a long time until we get
there. But you do see some data points now, the
at least one chamber has been lost every time
in modern times, with the exception of 2002,
which was the first election after the 9 11
attacks. And we lived in a very different
America. We lived in a crisis in America. But
if you set that aside George W. Bush, you know,
the clinton White House, they lost seats. We all
remember the Obama shellacking. They lost 63 seats
in his first midterm trump. Lost 20 something
seats in his first midterm. And because the
margin is so close in the House, it is still the
republican expectation, some democrats think they
can defy even this one. But I'm a bit skeptical.
I would need to see more data, but you know,
since it only takes a handful of seats to swing,
most republicans still think they get the House,
but the Senate is manu noted is now 50 50.
Do not forget these governors races in the
state legislative races anyway, they often get
ignored in Washington as we work in Washington,
they're always important anyway. They're hyper
important this year because governors are going
to have to deal with the abortion question.
Does your governor sign or veto a bill for
abortion restrictions? Does that governor,
he or she have a veto proof majority in the
the election questions, we can talk about perhaps
contesting election results that all falls to
governors and legislatures and secretary
of state. So don't forget the state races.
But I do think what is fascinating here, we can
get into the numbers in the individual races
is just how consequential this is. We will
live in a very different Washington. If joe
biden for the second half of his term as a
Republican Senate and a Republican house,
that's one Washington, we could have think of how
different that Washington would be if we had a
Democratic Senate, if the democrats hold on.
And even if kevin McCarthy become speaker or
republicans take the house. But with a very
narrow majority, If that's what happens,
Joe biden has a lot more influence. If he has a
Democratic Senate, he has to compromise a ton.
He has to listen to republicans a lot more if
they control both chambers. But if the democrats
can somehow hold onto the Senate and keep even if
there is a Republican majority, keep it narrow,
then the speaker of the house, presumably,
McCarthy, but maybe not, certainly McCarthy If
that majority is narrow, but the Republican leader
in the House would be as worried about his or her
right flank. Um, then joe biden if that majority
is narrow, The consequences here at every level
are just enormous and the uncertainty I've been
doing this for almost 40 years. I do not remember
sitting eight weeks out looking at the first
midterm climate. The first one is usually the
one where you have the big swing and having such
so many questions and so many conflicting data
points. No, it's so true. And so Daniella, I want
to bring in our a viewer questions and remember
if you're watching and you have a question,
please feel free to submit. This is from brian
in pennsylvania. What are the implications for
the next two years if the republicans gain back
control of either the House or the Senate?
I mean, there are a lot of implications, but
I'm guessing somebody who covers the House well,
you cover both, but particularly the House, um,
having the gavels on the republican side will
change the dynamic in a lot of ways. Right?
That's right, dana. Now, I have not been
doing this nearly 40 years, like john,
but in my experience in covering Congress these
past couple of years, I was on the presidential
campaign in 2020. It would just be very, very
tricky for the biden administration to get any
legislation through. Should, uh, what we predict
the House be taken by republicans should democrats
keep the senate. It's just as john said, it would
be incredibly complicated is uh a car becomes
house speaker. He could of course put his own
legislative agenda as we've seen as he's been
giving, he gave a speech just last week, really
nailing down these issues that we're going to see
from house republicans. Should they take back
the majority, if democrats keep the senate,
they're going to push their own agenda with
the biden administration, which would be
just a block on any legislation that we could
see happening in the next two years. Should
that happen? Which is a prediction that a lot
of people are making right now. Dana. Yeah.
And this is another question from our viewers
Monica from texas manu. I'll start with you.
Do you think Clarence thomas regrets overturning
roe versus wade based on the fact that women
are turning out in droves to vote the GOP out in
Kansas Alaska specifically. Additionally, do you
think there will be ramifications for his wife's
role in him being the single vote to overturn
the election? I don't, I'm not sure about the
second part. Um that's what that means, but the
first part is obviously the key and obviously
wasn't just Clarence thomas who said that roe
versus wade should be overturned. Uh, there
were several more justices 66 to 3, right? So,
um, you know, all of trump's appointees.
And uh, and then some said that this is
uh that this should be overturned. So what are you
hearing on that notion? It are you hearing sort of
be careful what you wish for from some republicans
who worked for generations to see this day and now
they're out there now they have
to campaign with this reality.
Yeah, no doubt about it. And I don't think
Clarence thomas regrets this at all effect
his dissent when even further in suggesting that
other presidents could be overturned, such as
same sex marriage being one of them. And that's
one issue that is now animating Congress. Now,
there is a big fight, a big push in the
Senate to be codified same sex marriage
rights across the country and interracial
marriage over concerns that perhaps that
the future courts could look at what thomas said
in his dissent and used that as president to rule
against same sex marriage and eventually
get his way up to the Supreme Court. So,
so undoubtedly his words had meaning and really
impact on the political dynamic, even though he
wasn't in the majority on that part. Of course,
he was in the majority in overturning roe versus
wade. And that is Reality that Republicans are
dealing with right now, and it is a bit of a
dog caught the car moment because they have been
pushing for this for so long. But the messaging
on the Republican side has sort of been all
over the place, some support federal ban. Some
don't support any exceptions at all? Some support
exceptions for rape or incest? Some are okay with
restrictions after 20 weeks. Someone in 15 weeks,
others saying we should leave it up to in the
states and what they don't want to do is talk
about this issue in the midterms. Republicans
want the debate to be about the economy, want
the debate to be about inflation, about biden's
job performance generally about Afghanistan.
Everything the biden administration has done wrong
when they're talking about abortion. Republicans
will acknowledge that they are losing even as
they're trying to have a democratic positions is
being outside of the mainstream by not supporting
restrictions. Even their third trimester, they
are still having a difficult time staying united
messaging on this issue, even though they were
on the winning side of this. So this will be
this is the big uncertainty as we head into
the midterms. As john noted, there has been
so much energy on the democratic side and it had
success in some of these house special elections.
Will that translate into november? That's the big
question here. Democrats see this as a winning
issue. Republicans don't, which is
why they want to change the subject,
john, I'm gonna put this next viewer question to
you because you did a segment on your show today
about on inside Politics. About pennsylvania. And
this question is from Denise from pennsylvania.
What are your thoughts on what's happening
in pennsylvania? It's always an interesting
political state, but even more so this year,
the commonwealth, Let's give it its respect as
a citizen of the child, of the commonwealth of
massachusetts. I'll always remember pennsylvania
is a commonwealth as well, but it's also a
state and it's one of our most competitive look,
just go through the last couple of presidential
elections and look ahead to the next couple of
presidential elections this year. You have a race
for governor. That is absolutely essential. Again,
because of the snakes of the abortion debate. The
election denial debate. Election integrity debate.
You have a fascinating race for United States
Senate. That is one of those opportunities. The
republican incumbent, Pat Toomey, who's retiring
and democrats? No, they're 50 50 math is motto
and daniella know it better because they're up on
capitol hill all the time and they see this 50 50
play out, the democrats are worried. So maybe
we're gonna lose somewhere so we could pick up
that republican seat. Sure, that helps us, right?
It's a buffer, puts the puts the republicans on
their heels. They're just fascinating races. You
have interesting candidates, candidates, both
in the Senate race, both in lieutenant governor
Fetterman and dr Oz, unorthodox and interesting
candidates despite your perspective in a state
that, you know, trump just barely wins it in 2016
biden wins it by a little bit more, but still a
very competitive election in 2020. The thing, my
biggest question we can talk about the candidates,
we can talk about the issues. Um Pennsylvania is
one of the places that in both 2018 and in 2020
we saw a turnout go up 2018 was a midterm that
defied normal midterms turnout was high. So are we
in a tree back to a traditional midterm setting?
Because trump's not in the White house. Everyone
said in 2018 that was the trump effect. Everybody
voted because trump polarizes people and get them
to vote. Is that true? Trump's not on the ballot,
but he's back. Some will we see in pennsylvania
and the other battle grounds unusually high
midterm first midterm turnout. What normally
happens is the President's party drops off
a little bit the other party. The opposition has
the energy and they they come out because they're
excited to kick essentially to kick the party in
power and that's why the party in power tends to
lose because pennsylvania is so close. And because
the Dobbs issue has so changed the debate in the
suburbs. If you go back to traditional elections,
crime, immigration inflation. Those are the issues
the republicans wanted to run out in the suburbs
because they were punished in the sea suburbs
because of trump in 2018, punished again
in the suburbs because of trump in 2020.
They thought they could win the suburbs in
2022. In places like pennsylvania where they
are critical and close races because of those
issues. But now suddenly dobbs abortion rights,
tolerance, democracy back in play. That's the
tug of war. Who wins the debate in the next
eight weeks about what should be number one when
you vote? What should be the defining issue? So
I think there are a couple of states. George is
another one. Arizona is another one we could say.
But if you're looking at the laboratories of
in a in a truly purple state in a really wild
and unpredictable midterm year, I could camp
out in pennsylvania every day until the end.
Um Daniella, this is a new question that just
came in from mark and New Jersey. Is there an
urgency for the houses January 6th committee to
conclude its work before the midterm elections?
Well, even Jamie Raskin said this past weekend
that he's expecting the report to be released by
the end of the year. He didn't even say possibly
before the midterms. But if the republicans take
back the House, which is what is expected Dana
and Mark from New Jersey, the problem is that
committee will cease to exist. They won't have
the power that they have right now to subpoena to
investigate. Of course, republicans have called it
a Sky a scam of a worthless investigation. They've
called it out including, you know, possibly the
future House Speaker kevin McCarthy. So that's why
the clock is ticking for these members to finish
this investigation and also keep in mind that
there are two republicans on this committee who
are not going to serve in Congress this next term,
The one retiring Adam Kinzinger, another who lost
her primary just two weeks ago, Liz Cheney. So
that's why the clock is ticking for them to finish
this in investigation. Of course the plan was to
have them have this report come out before the
midterms. Uh they wanted to be able to uh educate
voters on what happened following january 6th.
You know, john just mentioned that issue of how
democracy has been uh topic that voters are
turning out to the polls for. So that is why
the clock is ticking and why they're trying to get
this through before november but clear right now,
considering Jamie Raskin just said on sunday on
one of the morning shows that I watched the, he
thinks that will come out by the end of the year,
that major report that they've been working on
since they started this investigation, it has to
at least before republicans take control. I mean,
these, the republicans, you talked about who are
on the committee Liz Cheney and Adam Kinzinger
are going to be in office until the new congress,
which which doesn't happen until january and you
know, you when you said Kinzinger and Cheney won't
be here. Um it's so true and we have to remember
both of them are not going to be in Congress
because of Donald trump in various ways.
Various dynamics played into it. Um For Liz
Cheney was the actual voters who threw her out
who chose trump. Um And his frankly his lies
over Cheney manu. I want to ask you about um
Ohio we talked to just a minute ago about
pennsylvania. You went to Ohio to do a story on
the senate race there. J. D. Vance and
tim Ryan. What did you find or not find?
I didn't find J. D. Vance on the campaign. I was
out there searching for him and I did uh did reach
out to his campaign hoping to see him in action.
Uh He was not doing any public campaigning. He
said that his campaign said he's only having
private events and that has been in keeping
with the way he has conducted his campaign since
winning his primary recalled he is the first time
candidate, he is the former author of the book,
Hillbilly Elegy and former venture capitalist.
Someone who ran the campaign and the crowded
primary and really seemed like he was on the outs
until Donald trump came behind and supported him
in that crowded primary. And suddenly he emerged
victorious behind that in the backing of Peter
thiel the uh big Republican donor who dropped
about 15 million or so into a super pac to boost
Vance but when Vance emerged he really didn't have
much of an infrastructure. He didn't have much of
a campaign staff didn't have a big donor network
and had to work on repairing bridges and it took
him some time to find his footing. He didn't,
he struggled fundraising. His last fundraising
report showed him in debt and also showed him
raising just a fraction of money as his Democratic
opponent, tim Ryan, who has been pouring tons and
tons of money across the airwaves to try to
burnish an image of a moderate independent
person. He doesn't mention he's a democrat in this
increasingly conservative state. In some ways,
he sounds like a Republican. He says, I voted for
the trump trade policies. I voted again against
Barack Obama trade policies and talking to
some voters and some other strategists and he
looking at his ads, they're effective because
he comes across as someone who does not,
is not part of what is unpopular Democratic brand
in his state. And I asked him right about why he
doesn't advertise the democrat. He said, well,
it is not, uh, it's not, the brand is not good
in some parts of the state and of course it's
a largely rural state. So, um, the campaign,
while Vance has not been on the trail as much,
he's expected to show his face more in public
in the post Labor Day and he's also benefiting
greatly from $28 million that mitch McConnell
super pac plans to pour across the airwaves in
the final two months of the campaign. That is a
ton of money that initially republicans thought
would be spent elsewhere, not on what they had
thought was a safe seat and a log and that could
have an impact across the map as a way resource
decisions in the final weeks of where to spend
their money in these key races. So republicans
believe they will win. Ohio because of this late
money coming in from mitch McConnell super back.
But let's see what kind of impact it could have in
some other races as they make those key decisions
late about whether to spend money to say trying
to win colorado for instance, or perhaps put more
money into Wisconsin. Those are big decisions as
money decisions that they make a big difference.
Yeah. And if you want to know where the party
thinks the trajectory of a particular race is
going, that's you just have to follow the money
to see where big super pacs like mitch McConnell's
are spending their money and how much And
same with the, with the democrats as well.
I was in michigan last week also had a lot of
trouble. In fact, I was unsuccessful at talking
to the Republican candidate for governor.
Their tutor Dixon. They just said flat. No,
she had no public events, no interview.
They wouldn't provide a sir get nothing. So
I think in her case she's spending a lot of time
raising money. Um, but it's a really interesting
trend that we're seeing among republicans,
I guess they just think that they can
spend money when people are paying attention
closer to the election to define themselves. It's
just a question of whether they are already being
defined as we speak by their Democratic opponents.
Um, john this is for you, uh Jonathan from new
york since trump turned the political system
upside down. Is there anything normal to
rely on in our governing governing bodies?
Well, there are a number of ways you could come at
that one. Look, trump was completely unorthodox,
right? Remember all the people who said he has no
way he could win the Republican nomination. And
then he plowed through a very experienced field of
politicians and he did. Everyone said he couldn't
win the presidency. He he did. Um and so how
government worked this whole controversy. Now,
investigation of the sensitive documents,
classified documents taken to mar a Lago,
you can come at this 100 different ways, if not
1000 different ways of how trump either. Put some
previous issues like polarization, polarization
existed before trump. He put it on steroids,
the Republican focus on issues like immigration
other norms or more trumpian, if you will specific
to trump in the context of what we're about to go
through. I think it connects to the conversation
you were just having last night in my home state
massachusetts a trump guy won the Republican
nomination for governor most smart republicans
now. Think that guarantees a democratic governor
in massachusetts massachusetts has a history.
Bill. Well paul Cellucci, the current governor
charlie baker of sometimes electing a moderate
Republican governor as a check on the majority
democrats in massachusetts. Americans tend to like
divided balanced government. The the governor of
Maryland, larry Hogan can't run for re election,
his choice to replace him beaten by a trump
nominee in pennsylvania. We talked about
earlier the trump nominee beating more mainstream
republicans, even a pretty conservative Republican
and former congressman Lou Barletta. But
a couple of other guys from the business
who did well where only in the suburbs around
philadelphia where republicans need to win.
So I do think we are having a trump effect in this
race. And I think in part a lot of republicans are
now if we're having this conversation six months
ago, even three months ago Um the conversation
would be the race that matters for Republicans
is the primary because if J. D. Vance can win
that nomination. He's the next senator from Ohio.
You know if tutor Dixon can win that nomination,
she's probably the next governor for Michigan
because people saw a red wave building or at
least a certain big red year building. We live
in a different world now and in that different
world I would argue experience can matter in the
hand to hand combat of a 5050 election in these
key battleground states. The fact that J. D.
Vance for republicans I get it. He's unorthodox
a lot of democrats and republicans sometimes look
for people outside the system like donald trump
because they're frustrated. They're disaffected.
They don't think the politicians listen to them.
I get that completely and I respect voters
when they're looking for something different.
But in the hand to hand combat in
the final days of a close campaign
often the best politician wins. And sometimes that
politician is a guy. Maybe it's I'm not saying tim
Ryan's gonna win in Ohio but that race is close
because there's a guy who knows where can I talk
like a democrat where can I embrace the unions For
example where you can both embrace the unions and
the trump trade policy. Right? That that might not
sound like it makes but you do that. So knowing
your state governor Whitmer has won before
a lot of people watching this who might not
like Governor Whitmer for whatever reason. Maybe
they're just republicans. Maybe they're democrats
who didn't like the covid policies but she's done
it before. That's my point that we live in a very
different climate now where it's not a full wind
at the back of these republicans. So I think when
we go through these races. The trump effect could
be that they can't match him. He was an unorthodox
guy with no political experience who managed to
win the presidency. Which, again whatever you
think of Donald trump is a wow that is hard to do
it. So wow, can these other candidates match that?
Do they have the, are they so unorthodox?
They can tap into their states or does the
more experienced politician beat them in the end?
Because when it's close often that matters? Yeah,
no it does. And it's important to differentiate
between what you're alluding to here statewide
races and blue leaning or pro bowl or maybe even
republican states like Ohio um, for governor and
senate and then the house races. So Daniella,
when you're talking about the trump factor that
both manu and john were alluding to, it plays out
quite differently in the house races because of,
of gerrymandering. And so many of these of these
districts are hardcore red or hardcore blue,
There's so few swing districts that would play out
the way the statewide races are playing. So, so
republicans in the house sort of treat and look at
trump in a different, more welcoming way. Right?
Exactly. I mean, they've been successful in
embracing trump the way they have. That's
why you've seen more moderate, uh, people in
leadership, republicans in leadership go shift
toward trump. If you remember at least Stefanik
used to be a more moderate member in Congress.
She was actually more moderate uh, than even Liz
Cheney and her voting record before she became
the GOP conference chair, obviously it suited
her to move to more conservative embraced trump
we've seen kevin McCarthy in the last few
years really embraced trump as many people
say history and and that part has been able to win
over members of the House Freedom Caucus, the more
conservative members of his party keep people like
marjorie, taylor Greene on his side. People, he's
going to need dana when he runs for speaker when
the House wins. Uh, excuse me when republicans win
the House. Now, another factor in all of this that
we haven't even mentioned is that when republicans
take over, they're going to start investigations
on the biden administration, they're going to
possibly try to impeach president joe biden. This
is all going to be part of what we're going to
see these next two years when republicans take
back the House. And that is why of course these
republicans, we're still seeing that there should
have a small margin. You know, manu had a really
good story with our colleague Melanie's about
how republicans are seeing that there's going
to be a smaller margin, possibly not as large of
a margin considering all these wins. The biden
administration has had in legislation the past
couple of weeks including inflation production
act, but they're still likely going to take the
majority have a small margin. And we're going to
see their power in these committees, like most
likely the House oversight committee when they
take over and what they're going to do against
the biden administration against democrats uh, and
enforce that power to investigate. You know, the
political bibles that they have been. Yeah, well,
thomas Danielle, just staying with you quickly,
thomas from Hawaii asks the very question that you
just brought up, which is uh republicans thinking
about impeaching joe biden already. If they have
the gavel and and the ability to investigate his
question though, is are there any republicans
worried about overreaching and appeal to their
base if they take back the majority in the House?
Well, if you want to count the 10 republicans
that impeach donald trump uh to last year,
last january, only two right now are
possibly coming back uh to Congress.
So that really shows where things stand right now
with house republicans and uh you know what they
feel about trump, what they feel about joe biden.
And uh you know, they've already hinted multiple
times made comments to order and, you know,
this McCarthy last week that they're planning
to investigate joe biden and that's really where
the party is headed. And they, Are there any
moderates that do not believe that that's the way
the party should go. It's likely that they don't
have the support from the majority of the party.
And that is what, you know, these republicans that
are going to be in these powerful committees have
hinted, for example, James Comer, who's probably
going to be the chairman of the house oversight
committee, plans to investigate Hunter biden.
So that is going to be what we're going to see
when republicans take back the House and there's
really no stopping them. Should they continue
with the momentum that they have now? Yeah,
I can I can I just I mean, that is always the
risk of a majority and always overreaching. You
see it time and time again. They come in with a
head of steam. It could be on the republican side,
the democratic side and a huge agenda. Oftentimes
they misread their mandate. They go beyond what
voters elected For. It could have some impact.
Actually could potentially help Joe biden in
some ways, assuming Joe Biden runs for reelection
and he has a foil to run against the Republican
House. In fact, if it comes to that, Obama did the
same thing after losing the house in 2010. He ran
against the House Republicans in 2012. Use that
as a successful strategy. You know, the challenge
for the republicans is going to be in addition to
these investigations that they will undoubtedly
law and launch the pressure that McCarthy would
face assuming his speaker to impeach is actually
getting the basic functioning of government done.
They still will have to fund the government. They
will have to raise the national debt ceiling early
in the new congress. That avoid what could be the
first ever debt default in the United States.
That is going to be an incredibly tricky issue
because no republican wants to vote for that.
But ultimately some votes will have to come from
the GOP side, democrats don't want to vote for
that either they may try to attach things to it,
it's gonna be a huge, huge mess. So that is one
big reason why McCarthy's super pac has spent
so much money to try to build what they call a
quote governing majority, which gives them some
cushion on the republican side, not a single digit
majority, which would allow that right flank to
really control what McCarthy does. But for him to
ignore that right flank and do something with more
people in line with his viewpoint, his ideology,
whether they get there is another question,
but it is a recipe for what could be a pretty
messy couple of years if that plays out such,
such an important point. I mean we all covered
speaker Boehner had a giant majority but had a
very tough time governing because they were all
over the place at that point. It was the Freedom
caucus, they were upset about spending and it was
pre trump. And then paul Ryan more recently, just
kind of had well, lots of troubles, but the
main trouble, main challenge he had was being a
traditional republican in the age of trump.
Um, and the question is john whether or not,
I mean this is an unanswerable question, but
whether or not you just look at the battleground
districts at the battlefield, the political
battlefield whether or not McCarthy or
whomever is speaker. If the Republicans take
over even have the option for something that
is really big in order to be able to govern.
Because again, there are so few swing states and a
lot of swing districts rather. And a lot of those
that existed. Republicans already won in 2020.
There, the availability of the map barring a
giant wave is much smaller. You know, as I said,
Obama lost 63 trump, lost 42 or 43. You can't do
that anymore because of the redistricting. I mean,
it's possible if you have a giant giant
wave, but just set that out of your mind.
But again, if you go back 3456 months, people
were thinking the republicans could get 20 plus
maybe 30 seats. And that would give kevin McCarthy
that wiggle room, that would give him the ability,
you know, to ignore some of the agitators
sometimes or to give people a pass on tough votes,
like the debt ceiling on tough votes. Like
other things saying, I don't need your vote.
I understand you can't sell this back home.
Great, you can vote no, because I got enough
votes over here. Um, you would think you would
think that democrats would be thrilled and they
will be thrilled uh democrats want to keep the
house if they don't they of course want kevin
McCarthy to have or the republicans to have the
smallest possible majority. However, that will
make joe biden's job even more difficult because
that because the republican leader will be getting
flak from the right all the time. And the answer
being no, no, no. We agree that nothing. No, no,
no. So that will be fascinating to watch if you're
at home and you're trying to figure out, you know,
which races should I watch? How do I figure this
out? Uh Mono and Danielle Atkins, please jump
in. If you disagree. The ones I start with and
then you take the map from there is that there
are 7 16 members of Congress, nine republicans and
seven democrats who go home to districts carried
by the other guy, meaning seven democrats will
go home to districts carried by trump. If this is
a Republican year, those seven should be in deep
trouble. Right? If this is a big Republican year,
they're going home to districts that in a
presidential year when Democratic, your guy,
one joe biden won, so turnout was up. They should
be in trouble. Are they? How many of them survive?
I think one is not running for re election. But
how many how many of those districts send back
democrats? And then there are nine republicans who
go home to districts carried by joe biden Again in
a traditional first term midterm drop off. They
should be okay or at least better than they were
when they had to fight hard in a presidential
year, are they? The Democrats think at least
one who happens to be one of that impeachment
10 in California because there's some suburban
districts in California, but the Democrats
think they can get two or three republicans
who are in biden districts or just trump districts
because of the politics of row, the politics of
dogs and the registration. So we talked about
these data points, where is the president's
approval rating? It's still historically low, but
it's trending that way, voter registration among
women trending that way. So the trends right now
suggests that the environment every day is getting
a little bit better for the democrats. How much
better? That's why we have eight fascinating weeks
ahead of us. And, and does it possibly change the
gas prices start going up again instead of down,
there's something happening in the world that
we're not even thinking about today. So there's a
lot of potential changes in the dynamic. But right
now the trend lines and for several weeks now the
trend lines have been favoring the democrats.
Republicans are trying to bend that back.
We'll see if they succeed. We're almost out of
time. Daniella want to start with you. And then
manu tell me one thing that you're hearing from
your sources that we haven't had a chance to talk
about that. People out there should be looking
at and looking for in the next eight weeks. Well,
I'm kind of a cliche, but of course the thing that
I'm paying attention to this, where Latinos vote,
um, as a Latina and also from where I'm from,
there's three very competitive races taking place,
the valley where republicans are
pumping money into trying to uh,
switch those seats. In fact, there's already a
republican. One of the seats, Maria flores has
gathered a lot of attention uh in the past couple
of weeks when she replaced for that seat. But
anyway, um, right now, I mean, Latinos are not a
monolith, That's always something we say over and
over again. But a lot of Latinos are incredibly
concerned. Recent polls have shown that roe v wade
has become a major issue for them. Uh, and that's
what is dictating how they might vote in the
midterms. And that is something that I'm watching.
And something I find very interesting considering
that is an issue that just came up, you know,
since the Supreme Court ruled against Rome.
And usually Latinos are more interested
in issues like the economy or opportunity,
inflation. And those are all issues, of course the
border, those are all issues immigration that they
are concerned with. But most recently that weight
issue, abortion being super major, but that's not
only true of Latinos everyone, but particularly
with Latinos. I find that very, very interesting.
And the question is whether or not the, I
wouldn't call it a trend, but the question of
latino voters voting more Republican, not just
in the border communities where you're from,
but in the interior of the of the country as
well. Um manu. So even though the things the trend
and the conventional wisdom has has been that
republicans are struggling in the Senate races,
there is still a serious, serious chance that they
can win back the majority. And the mitch McConnell
still has high hopes and believes that Mehmet
Oz is gonna win the pennsylvania Senate race.
Despite polling showing Fetterman up, there's
a belief among top republicans that perhaps
Arizona it will be difficult to pick up given the
performance so far blank Masters, the Republican
candidate there, herschel walker has struggled on
the campaign trail, but republicans still think
there's a serious chance that they could pick
up that seat in Georgia, but watch out for other
states that just really have not gotten nearly
as much attention. New Hampshire being one of
the Maggie Hasson. She is an incumbent Democratic
senator. There's a late primary this month to pick
the republican candidate against her republicans
failed in trying to get the gover Sununu to run
against her in that race. But McConnell, superman
super pac is coming in late for candidate chuck
morse in that race, democrats are hoping another
candidate that far right candidate Don Baldock
will emerge from that primary. How
that primary shapes up could determine
whether Maggie hasn't is vulnerable, McConnell
gets his pick. Perhaps that race could be very,
very tight. It could also potentially flip that
would be a huge pickup for the GOP and also the
GOP does not get as much attention Nevada. Such
a key ST Catherine Cortez masto up against a
Republican candidate there who has the support of
trump and McConnell so that there is so much to go
in this this midterm election season, even though
it's just two months even though the belief
is that republicans probably won't get back
the majority. No one should should suggest
that that's what's going to happen here because
a lot can happen and will happen and can turn
just in the final weeks of the election. So I'll
just add one other race to that Washington State
Patty Murray who has been for 30 years. She
has she has a race. I interviewed both. She
and her Republican challenger. Tiffany Smiley
Murray's taking her seriously and is raising
a lot of money and is getting out there. So that
could be a sleeper. We'll see how that plays out.
Yeah that's another potential sleeper a lot to
keep everybody busy and everybody interested
because we know the stakes are incredibly high and
all of this matters for a whole host of reasons.
Thank you all great talking to you and we'll see
you soon. Thank you so much for joining us. Please
follow CNN dot com backslash citizen to R. S.
V. P. For more talks. Have a great afternoon